my name is edition I'm from bin liu what
is the role of science and technology in
21st century to the mankind and all the
life of Anna yes of course so we start
the 21st century with many problems the
part of energy in the difficulty of
finding energy after the end of the oil
the point of climate the program of
water in many countries and so of course
we will be able to solve all this
problem with the help of science exam
science can to find new source of energy
from the Sun with cellular cells also to
solve the parameter primate to control
the concentration of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere and so on so science will
be important to solve all these new
problem of humanity